Die Das Podcast UFO-Intervorsitzenden. Florentin DeFlo und Stefan Stefan Tietze präsentieren Das Podcast UFO. Goldrichtig seid ihr hier, wenn ihr nach dem Podcast UFO gesucht habt.
Schön, dass ihr da seid. Mein Name ist Florentin Will. Und mein Name ist Stefan Tietze. Wir begrüssen euch zu einer fantastischen neuen Ausgabe, nämlich die wievielte? Die Folge vier, zwei, acht, alles durch zwei, teilbar und dann nochmal durch zwei teilbar. Und dann sind wir bei der zwölf, wie immer. Stefan, schön, dass du da bist. Herzlich willkommen. Stefan Titzelmeister, Merlin Gundelin habe ich mir hier aufgeschrieben. Ist das ein Künstlername oder was? Das ist mein alter Name. Merlin Gundelin? Ich habe den noch im Autocomplete gefunden. Ich habe gegoogelt. Stefan Tietze und dann kam Merlin Gundelin. Das darf niemand jemand wissen, dass es ein Name ist. Es tut mir leid, aber ich weiss noch nicht, was die Quelle ist, aber es war einfach Autocomplete. Also es war Stefan Tietze Reichtum, Stefan Tietze drei Millionen woher, Stefan Tietze Freundin, Stefan Tietze Freundin woher, Stefan Tietze The Happening und dann Stefan Tietze Merlin Gombolin. Das ist dein alter Name. Aber das tut mir leid. Das ist ein alter Name. Gibt es da irgendwie, wenn man den dreimal sagt, dass dann irgendwie … Mich! Niemals den dreimal hintereinander sagen. Was soll ich nicht dreimal hintereinander sagen? Ich hab mich so gefragt, also Dämonen müssen so ganz klaren Regelkompass haben. Ja. Weil wenn ich jetzt dreimal hintereinander Bloody Mary, da würde ich nicht einen Horrorfilmer irgendwann schreiben würde oder daran beteiligt werde, würde ich das sofort zum Thema machen. Was für, also wie viel Zeit muss vergehen? Ich sage zum Beispiel, genau, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary und dann gehe ich einen Monat ins Schweigeschloster, komme zurück, sage Bloody Mary und dann ist jemand hinter mir? Direkt? Ja, ja. Oder ist es so, ist so wie, wenn man bei der Wartesteife ist, drücken Sie bitte die Eins, man wartet zu lange, dann fliegt man heraus. Richtig. Irgendwann ist die Eins einfach ein neuer Teil der Nummer. Du hast nur vierzig Minuten Zeit, deine Entscheidung zu treffen, sonst bist du raus. Aber wie ist das Bloody Mary, wenn die einmal genannt wird, dann zieht die sich schon die Schuhe an? Oder sagt die erstmal, für einmal stehe ich nicht von der Couch auf? Für einmal, das ist wie so, das kann passieren. Okay, ja, das kann jedem mal passieren. Genau. Das ist wie so eine unbekannte Nummer ruft an, man geht erst mal nicht ran. Ah klar, verstehe. Dann ruft sie noch mal an. Und du merkst, oh, ist eine Kölner Vorwahl. Ja. Oh, und dann ist man schon alarmiert so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, am ersten Mal macht sie nichts, am zweiten Mal macht sie alles. Am zweiten Mal macht sie sich bereit. Zieh die Jacke an. Weil niemand sagt zwar Bloody Mary, ohne dann das dritte Mal Bloody Mary zu sagen. Ja, das stimmt. Viele in Bars unterwegs wahrscheinlich auch, ne? Also viele Kellner ist ein grosses Problem. Ich spreche mit Gin Tonic. Ja, Riesenproblem. Ich weiß gar nicht, was eine Bloody Mary ist. Jemand, der seinen Witz zu geil findet. Alle reden schon über was anderes. Stefan Tietze trinkt gerade einen Red Bull, das wird eine wilde Folge. Also, ich glaube, heute bleibt jemand lange wach. Nein, nein, nein, nein, sie sind doch nicht brauche. Wegen des Drinks. Stefan Tietze stürtet sich wirklich in Niagara-Fällen artiger Geschwindigkeit hier die Zuckerbrause in die Kehle. Ich bin gespannt, was das heute für eine Folge wird. Du bist anders, wenn du trinkst. Du bist anders, wenn du voller Zucker bist. Ich habe dich mal an Halloween erlebt, das war ein ganz anderer Mensch, sehr melancholisch, sehr in sich gekehrt. Der Metabolismus fährt runter. Fährt runter bei dir, da werden ganz viele Fettreserven angelegt bei dir, merkt man auch, die Wangen werden direkt ganz weich. Und rot. Und rot, aber dafür geht er in sich. Du meinst so, hey Leute, geil, dass wir heute mal zusammen sind an Halloween und du hast einmal Michelangelo-Turtle auf der einen Seite und irgendwie ... Ferio-Küsschen. Ferio-Küsschen auf der anderen Seite, die Haarepackung. Und dann wirst du ganz emotional und die alle Party, Party. Und du wirst so ganz emotional und erreichst sie auf dem Moment gar nicht. In dem Moment, wo man mit dir mal wirklich ernst, ohne diese Kunstfigur, Stefan Tietze, dieses Merlin-Gombolin-Ding. Hör auf, das zu sagen, wirklich. Ohne diese Kunstfigur könnte man da mal mit dir reden, aber dann findest du kein Ohr. Und ist das nicht die eigentliche Tragik von Halloween? Ich habe auch gedacht, es ist wahnsinnig lustig, wenn Leute haben ja einen verschiedenen Verlauf bei Substanzen, die sie konsumieren. Beispiel Koffein, Beispiel Alkohol. Ja, und der Verlauf ist ja meistens, sie werden entspannter, aber auch extatischer, euphorischer, lockerer im sozialen Umfeld. Und dann irgendwann wird es, es gibt ganz viele Verläufe, weil irgendwann kippt das so und dann ein Freund von mir wird dann immer so sehr, ganz am Ende dieser, dieser drei Akte, wird er so sehr in sich gekehrt, ruhig, melancholisch, grummelig. So ein bisschen wie dieses Milchspektrum. Milch, Buttermilch und dann geht es so weiter und es ändert sich teilweise radikal. Schlechte Milch, Käse. Käse, schlechter Käse, schlechter Käse, Harzer. Ja, und teilweise hast du radikale Änderungen drin, die auch teilweise Kreisbewegungen drin haben. Du hast ja ganz wilde Kurven auf jeden Fall. Weil wenn man einen Blauschimmelkäse länger liegen lässt, kommen da raus kleine Kühe. Ah, genau. Das wissen nämlich dann viele nicht. Ganz viele kleine Kühe. Das riefen kleine Kühe raus. Wenn man bei so einem Gorgonzola mal ganz genau hinguckt, sieht man auch die blauen Flecken, die blaue Kühe. Weil junge Kühe sind blau, die kommen raus, die kommen raus, die sind aber noch ganz klein, die laufen über den Tisch,
die laufen ganz schnell oder über die Geschmacksknospen, je nachdem, wenn man den Gorgonzola isst, dann laufen die quasi
stampedeartig über die Geschmacksknospen und das ist natürlich köstlich.
Stampedes. Stampedes. Stampedes.
Stampedes.
Laufen die da durch die Gegend.
Nee, wenn ihr euch den, haltet mal einen Gorgonzola ans Ohr, dann hört ihr so ganz leise.
Wenn man von denen dann wiederum Milch nimmt, ist es sehr kompliziert.
Diese winzigen Zitzen, da kommt man kaum ran.
Aber wenn man da wiederum nimmt, das ist dann ein ganz besonderer Gorgonzola, das ist dann richtig köstlich.
Gorg, wie ich gerne sage.
Das ist Gorgonzola. Dem sie mir ein Kilo Gorg. Das ist Gorgon Gorgonzola Zola. Ja, geben Sie mir ein... Das ist die Potenz. Richtig, ja. Geben Sie mir ein Gorg, sage ich ja oft bei mir an der Käsetheke, sage ich mir oft, geben Sie mir ein Kilo Gorg. Geben Sie mir zwei Kilo Gorg. Bist du so ein großer Gorgonzola-Fan tatsächlich? Bist du so ein frischer Thekentyp denn? Überhaupt gar nicht, nein, ich versuche es zu vermeiden mit aller Kraft und versuche wirklich mit Augenkontakt mit dem Metzgereiangestellten wirklich zum abgepackten Hackfleisch zu greifen, das dem armen Menschen den Arbeitsplatz nimmt und wirklich mit steifem Blick, steifes Glied, steifer Blick wirklich in die Augen greife ich zur Hackfleischtüte. Steifer Nacken, steifer Blick. Und kaufe dann auch nur diese Packung abgepackte, fertig Maschinen-Hackfleisch und leg nur das aufs Band. Und machst die noch im Laden auf. Nimmst das Stück und nimmst es langsam und leckst es einmal dran. Ja, leck einmal dran und werf es dann auf den Boden. Und dann weiss sie nicht, okay, weil du das, dann ist ja das Signal falsch. Aber das fand ich auch immer so löslich, weil die gucken ja auf ihr Verderben. Ja, ja. Das, in dem Rewe, in meinem Rewe des Vertrauens, wo ich immer hingehe, ist die frische Theke so vor Kopf des Ladens. Man stellt sich einen schlauchartigen Laden vor, hinten ist vor Kopf diese The, und die schauen auf alle abgepackten Fleisch- und Käsesorten.
Und dann stehe ich da immer und die haben oft, ich gehe zu Zeiten hin, da haben die nichts mehr zu tun, da stehen sie einfach nur dahinter und gucken. Und dann gehe ich da hin, trottel ich und gucke denen dann in die Augen und greife mir in die Frischtheke rein. Ja, ah, zum Glück ist noch eins da. Die abgepackte Theke. Zum Glück muss ich nicht mit Menschen reden. Ja. Ja, bei einem meiner letzten Ex-Ex-Supermärkten gab es die Veganabteilung direkt vor der Fleischtheke. Und da dachte ich auch, ihr wollt die Welt doch brennen sehen, oder? Also ist das hier ein soziales Experiment? Ist das hier ein Unbubble-Video, in das ich reingeraten bin? Was denn sonst? Naja, einfach ganz weit weg. Das ist so, den Antifa-Opa und den Nazi-Opa setzt du bei der Hochzeit ganz weit auseinander. Das ist ganz klare Hochzeitsplanung 1.01. Du setzt den mittelerfolgreichen Podcaster ganz weit weg von der Parteivorsitzenden der AfD. Das ist wirklich ganz klar. Das auch. Das ist das Dreieck. Also sonst hat der erfolgreiche Podcaster keine gute Zeit. Das ist das Dreieck. Und so, finde ich, muss man es im Supermarkt auch machen. Das machst du doch nicht. Du machst doch auch nicht die Laktose-Intoleranz-Sachen direkt neben die Milch. Das ist doch ein Pulverfass. Du machst doch auch nicht die Pasta neben die Antipasti. Das ist viel zu ... Die Pasti-Anziehungskraft ist viel zu stark dann. Das ist ja gepolt. Implodiert das Universum. Ja, das ist viel zu stark. Implodiert Italien. Das ist dann einfach so ein Loch im Universum. Und der Brenner ist dann zu. Und du kannst dann einfach nicht mehr rüber. Du kannst nicht über den Brenner. Du kannst nicht über den Brenner, weil man einfach sagt, nee, hier ist Voidzone. Hier ist jetzt die Voidzone. Die ist dann einfach ab da und dann geht es einfach nicht mehr weiter. Und wir fahren dann so, wir sind so die Ersten, die mit unserem Podcast Mobil, wenn sie da hinfahren, Mikrofone auf dem Dach geschnallt. Aber auch Lautsprecher. Lautsprecher auch aufs Dach. Wir speisen es direkt wieder raus, was reinkommt. Und dann haben wir so, so ein Fiat 500 müsst ihr euch vorstellen, so ein Mintgrüner. Oh ja. Und wir beiden natürlich, ne? Und Kennzeichen, D, P, U, Dortmund, P, U, genau, Düsseldorf, ähm, äh, P, U. Oh, Kfz-Lingend, Stefan Tietze, ja, für 10.000 Euro. Macht mir nichts vor, ich liebe Kennzeichen, viel zu sehr. Ebenfalls fand ich es gut, wenn wir in unserem mintgrünen Pferd Fuhunder dahinfahren, weil wir, ihr kennt uns, wir jagen der Story hinterher. Wir sind dort, wo die Schlagzeilen entstehen. Wir, DPU, Fuhfhundert, fährt also los und dann kommen wir dahin und da ist dann so ein Brachland. Weil da, wo früher Italien war, ist jetzt nichts mehr, eine Wüste. Wir fahren aber mit fahren aber mit 160 mit We're all in this together. Und währenddessen Florentin, wir hätten hier abgemusst. Und dessen Whiteshot und das Auto fährt einfach über so eine Klippe, einfach in so einen riesigen lila wabernden Dimensionsriss einfach. Und plötzlich, man hört noch, Florentin, wir hätten da vorne abgebob... Still. Florentin? Stefan? Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, Stefan. Tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin, tin,, olla. Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Intro, Florentin wäre so in Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien, Italien,. Und es kommen so ganz viele ganz kleine Italiener, die so ihre Hände halten und im Kreis um uns herumtanzen rufen, huldigung, huldigung, huldigung, ehe sie dann wieder in der Dunkelheit verschwinden. Und wir schauen in die Ferne und wir merken, dass dieses blaue Wabern, was wir gesehen haben, unendlich viele winzige Kühe sind. Mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, mu, Wie viele Fragen haben wir? Sagst du? Ja, sag ich. Blu und ihn? Ihr, ihr, ihr, ja. Du gehst direkt davon aus, ich nehme die erste zur Seite. Du gehst direkt davon aus, dass er uns drei Fragen... Stefan, ich dachte, wir dürfen, weil wenn wir jetzt von... Scusi. Scusat, Scusat. Weil ich dachte, der ist ja allmächtig, oder? Anscheinend. Ich habe jetzt einfach mal zwei, drei Schritte voraus. Und dann kann der uns ja Wünsche erfüllen. Und ich dachte, wir fragen direkt, wie viele habe ich. Nicht, habe ich eine Frage, sondern wie viele habe ich. Also du musst ja direkt sozusagen die Antwort vorwegnehmen. Das habe ich in einem Kurs gelernt, wie man Menschen manipuliert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt auch für Gorgonzola-Avatare im weitesten Sinne. Und in dem Moment sagt er, ich habe auf Zeit funktioniert. und löst sich in sich selber auf. Und damit, zack, sind wir zurück auf dem Brenner, Skier unter unseren Füssen, wir sind auf der schwarzen Piste, schnell, wedeln! Wedeln, wie wir es gelernt haben. Florentin hingegen hat ein Skateboard, wie wir es kennen aus der Folge, hat er oft genug erwähnt, hat ein Skateboard unter den, aber er ist falsch, falsch rumgeschnallt. Ja, die Rollen sind oben, im Darkslide quasi. Ach so, ja, okay. Im Darkslide, ja. Meinetwegen. Auf der schwarzen Piste. Ja, ja. Es passt alles zusammen. Ich springe auf einen Baumstamm. Plötzlich, Thais, versteckt sich hinterm Baum. Sie macht ein Foto von uns. Wahrscheinlich, weil sie gerade auf ihrer Mission ist. Was hängt da um ihren Hals? Im Lichtstrahl reflektiert ein Pulitzerpreis. Thais. Sie hat vielleicht ihre Doku in ihrer Hand. Ein Buch, ein Sachbuch erschienen, die Akte Domino. Und da auf ihrem Smartphone, welcher Podcast läuft da?
Gemischtes Hack.
Im Video, das Videopodcast.
Und Stefan Tietze wacht in seinem Bett auf, pochendes Herz.
Florentin, Florentin, er tastet mit der Hand neben und hat so ein merkwürdig flüssiges Gefühl an der Hand.
Oh Gott, Florentin, nicht schon wieder, nicht schon wieder. Das ganze Bett voller Gorgonzola. Schon wieder. Wir sind der zugänglichste Podcast der Welt. Wenn man mit dieser Folge anfangen sollte und noch dran ist, was keine der möglichen Abzweigungen dieses Wahrscheinlichkeitsbaums ist, falls doch, dann das waren alles Insider, basierend auf älteren Folgen. Richtig, Stefan Dietzer hat in Folge 186 erwähnt, dass ihm mal von dem Gorgonzola so schlecht wurde, dass er zwei Tage lang erbrochen hat und dann so starken Hunger hatte, aber in seiner Küche nur noch den halben Leib Gorgonzola übrig hatte.
Dass er wieder.
Dass er den wieder gegessen hat und nochmal zwei Tage erbrochen hat.
Und danach hat er sich was bestellt. Von Lieferando.
Ich hatte neulich bei Dominos bestellt, hatte es bei mir aufgemacht in der Nähe.
Und dann hatten die tatsächlich eine, die hatten die Chicken Strippers vergessen.
Ich sag, wie es ist. Die waren nicht dabei. Wo sind die jetzt? Hat sich jemand einverleibt. Aber das sind Stripper oder also sind das... Die heißen Chicken Strippers. Okay. Chicken Strippers. Du bestellst mehrere Stripper. Genau, das sind Chicken Fingers, aber die nennen es Strippers. Ach so, okay. Also keine Entkleidungskünstler im beidesten Sinne. Nein. Nein Gegenteil, angezogenes Chicken. Ah, paniertes Chicken. Wie Chicken Fingers, aber als Strippers. Die Finger von Hühnchen. Die heißen so. Das sind diese länglichen Filetstücke paniert. Ah, also so crunchy paniert oder so flockig. Nicht crunchy paniert, ganz normal paniert. Dann eher mit so einem Teig, so wie Chicken Nuggets eigentlich. Ja, eigentlich so wie, nein, nicht so wie Chicken Nuggets, noch was dazwischen, so wie ein Schnitzel. Wie ein Schnitzel? Okay. Jedenfalls kam das nicht mit, da wollte ich mich beschweren, aber die Dominus-App und die Website sind nicht darauf ausgelegt, dass es schief geht. Es gab keine Beschwerdefunktion, und jetzt warte ich bis heute auf mein Geld. Das kenne ich. Ich habe tatsächlich jetzt einen Brief bekommen von einem Carsharing-Unternehmen und da stand einfach drin, ja bitte nehmen Sie Stellung zum Unfall. Wann hat der Unfall stattgefunden? Wo hat der Unfall stattgefunden? Wo am Auto sind bei diesem Unfall Schäden entstanden? Wer bin ich? Was mache ich in diesem Raum? Und ich so, Sie sagen nicht mal Hallo oder was? Sie kommen rein. Herr Wann direkt. Sie haben viele Fragen. Gestehen Sie, dass Sie am Unfall schuld sind? Einfach bam, bam, bam. Und ich sitze da und denke mir, welcher Unfall denn? Hast du nicht mehr von dieser Doku True Confessions erzählt, wo Leute einfach mit so einer Taktik dann einfach zum Geständnis gezwungen wurden? Und wie kurz warst du vor dem Geständnis? Ich war kurz vor dem Geständnis. Also ich gestehe generell alles, aber ich wusste von keinem Unfall. So, und dann dachte ich so, okay, welcher Tag? Und an dem Tag hatte ich tatsächlich eine Automiete. Hatteest du einen Unfall? Hattest du einen Unfall mit dem Car-to-Go-Auto? Ja, aber der war tot, von daher, das weiss niemand. Aber egal, so. Und tatsächlich hatte ich an dem Tag eine Miete. Und ich wusste aber von keinem Unfall. Und dann habe ich, die haben mir dieses Formular geschickt per Mail. Und dann habe ich aber geantwortet, habe gesagt, ich weiss von keinem Unfall. Für mich lief die Fahrt tippitoppi. Ja? Liebe Grüße, Björn, Team, wähl. So sollte man viel häufiger schreiben. Ich dachte mir, ich biete mal was an. Schärfe rausnehmen aus solchen Konversationen mit tippitoppi. Ich will Service-Mitarbeitern, Hotline-Mitarbeitern immer sagen, ey, ich bin cool, beim ist alles okay. Ich bin einer von euch. Ich werde hier nicht, ich war mal einer von euch, mittlerweile bin ich Podcaster, aber ich war mal einer von euch. Okay. Und wenn ich es schaffen kann, statt mit einer Person. Ich habe eigentlich Anne gesagt, sie soll nicht diesen Podcaster neben mich hier setzen bei der Hochzeit. Statt mit einer, nee, weil der Hotline-Mitarbeiter redet mit einer Person. Ja. Ich hingegen rede mit vielen Personen. Ja, es werden weniger. Also es werden, es werden, wir sprechen weniger. Es werden sie kündlich. Oh scheiße. Mark, gemischtes Haar, verdammt nochmal! Wenn wir noch 20 Hörer verlieren, bist du wieder in einem Callcenter-Verhältnis. Ja, stimmt. Wir brauchen euch, dringend. Und dann kam als Antwort, bitte füllen Sie das Formular auf. Wo fand der Unfall statt? Wie viele Personen waren am Unfall beteiligt? Welches Auto hat gewonnen bei diesem Unfall? Und das System hat schlicht nicht vorgesehen, dass man die Prämisse hinterfragt. Und ich bin ja jemand, der hinterfragt die Prämisse. Ich frage direkt, Moment mal, ist deine Frage nicht auf den falschen Beinen? Steht deine Frage nicht auf ganz, ganz, ganz wackeligen Beinen. Wäre die erste Frage nicht, hatten Sie einen Unfall? Genau, ja. So, nicht, wie kann man Demokratie retten, sondern sollen wir. Aber ich als Wortschmied denke ja jetzt. Als Wortgaukeler, als Wortjongleur. Genau, als Wortjongleur, als Wortkonnisseur denke ich ja jetzt, man kann ja auch auf diese Fragen mit der Wahrheit antworten.
Stell mir die Fragen.
Wann fand der Unfall statt?
Na gut, das ist schon wasserdicht.
Das ist ein Problem, weil ich dachte mir, nee, ich mache jetzt nicht den Fehler und schreibe da irgendwas rein, nur um das Formular auszuwählen. Na, wir schreiben, wann fand der Unfall statt, du schreibst, welcher Unfall. Sie fragen, wo fand der Unfall statt? Bitte wählen Sie eine Uhrzeit aus, aus dem Dropdown-Menü. Ja, genau. Und ich so, schreib mit einem Kugelschreiber auf meinem Bildschirm, welcher Unfall. Vor allem, es muss einen neuen Begriff dafür geben, weil es gibt den Begriff zum Beispiel Road Rage. Die Wut im Auto. Und da hat man ja auch, wahrscheinlich so was wie Warteschlangen Rage, war auch mal ein Ding, wenn du so eine endlos Warteschlange bist und dir wird nicht geholfen. Jetzt müsste man ja eigentlich einen Begriff finden dafür, im Internet schlicht nicht weiterzukommen, weil es die Website nicht vorsieht. Also wie bei Dominos, ich konnte nirgendwo hinschreiben und du findest auch keine Mail. Wie viele Chickenfingers möchten Sie bestellen? Welche Soße möchten Sie zu den Chickenfingers? Warum gibt man mir auch so wenig Zeit? Warum ist alles in Caps geschrieben? Warum habe ich nur drei Sekunden? Ich weiß es nicht. Möchten Sie zu den Chickenfingers noch ein Getränk bestellen? Nein, eigentlich nicht. Schatz, möchte ich noch ein Getränk? Wir müssen dich jetzt entscheiden. Schatz, Wasser, Wasser, Wasser, Wasser! Sie haben 18 Chicken Nuggets, 14 Chickenfingers und zwei Liter Wasser bestellt. Okay, jetzt zur Zahlung. Das ist auf dem Weg zu Ihnen. Möchten Sie mit Karte oder Bar zahlen? Karte, Karte, Karte, Karte. Sie haben Bar ausgewählt. Oh mein Gott, wie ist das denn passiert? Und er ist direkt auf ihm, zum Weg zu ihm. Oh Gott, ich habe kein Bargeld. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich dieses Spiel mehrere Male gespielt. Ich habe geantwortet, welcher Unfall, ich weiss von keinem Unfall. Wie hast du das geantwortet? Im Dropdown-Menü? Auf die Mail geantwortet. Du bist in der Dropdown-Hölle. In diesem Ding, da gab es Möglichkeiten auszuwählen. Ich weiss noch, PDF, ich sage jetzt einfach mal PDF, ja, währenddessen alle Informatikfreaks, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, blinken die Brillen auf, ja, die, die, die, die, Cyphers, die Cyphers haben im Hackerspace. Die, die, alles blinkt vor sich hin, die Gehirndioden fangen an zu blinken, Das ist mir jetzt egal. Ich sage immer auf PDF.
Aber das ging nicht.
Und dann habe ich da mehrmals drauf geantwortet. Deine ganze Geschichte ist jetzt ab jetzt auf Sand gebaut für mich, weil du hast gerade gesagt Mail.
Genau.
Du kannst ja auf der Mail einfach mit Text antworten.
Jetzt pass auf.
Jetzt kommt's.
Medium, Inhalt.
Okay, wir fangen ganz vorne an.
Wir fangen ganz bei null.
Bedeutung.
Sätze, Wörter, Fragen, Antworten, Gross, Klein, Stefan, Pasti, Antipasti.
Und also in der Mail, stell dir die Mail wie ein Schiff vor. Nein, nein, nein, du machst viel zu schnell weiter. Das Schiff fährt durchs Meer, das Schiff fährt durchs Meer. Was für ein Schiff, weiss ich nicht. Das sehe ich von außen nicht. Was? Nur wenn es im Hafen ankommt. Nein, kannst du eine andere Metapher nehmen? Bitte, bitte, bitte. Ich verstehe nicht, wie du meinst. Stell dir die Mail als Schiff vor. Die Mail ist das Vehikel. Ja. Was ist drin? Das, was du schreibst. Sneaker, Bananen. Sag's mir, ich weiss es nicht. Aber du kannst ja in die Mail reinschreiben, ich habe keinen Unfall gebaut.
Ja, das habe ich ja genau gemacht.
Und dann? Aber in der Mail war eine, ich sage jetzt mal PDF-Struktur, ein Katalyst, ein Äther, ein alles um sich heransaugendes Konstrukt, ein Katafrakt im Allgemeinen. Ja, ja.
So, und das konnte ich eben nicht beantworten.
Ich konnte nur quasi auf dem,
auf der Medium-Ebene antworten,
nicht auf der inhaltlichen Ebene. Du konntest auf der Makro-Ebene antworten. Ja, wenn du so
möchtest. Aber,
ja, möchte ich gern. Okay. Aber
du bist ja nicht sicher, dass das jemals ankommt,
ne? Doch, das kam schon an, weil
relativ automatisiert geantwortet wurde,
sie haben mir
eine andere Antwort gegeben als das
ausgefüllte PDA
Vielen Dank. Doch, das kam schon an, weil relativ automatisiert geantwortet wurde, Sie haben mir eine andere Antwort gegeben als das ausgefüllte PDF. Und dann bitte füllen Sie das aus. Ich habe gesagt, ich hinterfrage hier gerade Prämissen. Weil du bist ja, du hast ein spezielles Problem, du bist in einer Art Sackgasse des Bot-Zeitalters gelandet. Korrekt. Ich hingegen will ja ganz einfach davor noch anfangen, verbietet No-Reply-Mail-Adressen. Ja. Weil immer wenn ich dann, dann schreibe ich Dominos, weil dann finde ich keine Hotline, ich finde das Dropdown-Menü nicht, ich finde nichts, diese App ist insanely schlecht. Also gehe ich auf die Website, gehe wie ein Boomer auf Impressum, weil ich weiß, rechtlich müssen sie da eine Mailadresse hinterlegen. Heinrich Böllstrasse 28, Rita, hol den Roller! Klicke auf hallo-at-domino.de oder Impressum-at-domino oder so und dann schreibe ich da hin und eine No-Replay-Mail, replayt mir, wo ich denke, das ist gar keine Augenhöhe da. Ja, ja, nicht überhaupt. Diese ganzen No-Replays, die mir, Replies, sorry.
Ersetzen durch Reply at Domino's. No-Reply, nicht Replay. Willingly Reply.
Warum hast du mich nicht am Anfang korrigiert? Das ganze Bit. Nicht wichtig. Ja, aber das können wir jetzt nicht bei TikTok posten. Er versteht es. Weil du sonst zu dumm dastehst, oder wie? Ja, ich stehe bei TikTok eh schon zu dumm da. Du hast keinen guten Ruf auf TikTok tatsächlich. Wenn man dich erwähnt mal so, ich habe ja ein paar Undercover-Accounts, wenn man dich mal so erwähnt nebenbei. Undercover-Accounts. Also ich folge da so Gartenkanälen, so wie kriege ich die Schnecken aus dem Garten raus? Und dann schreibe ich, ja, ich habe letztens mit dem Garten gearbeitet und dabei das Podcast Ufo mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will gehört. Ach, Stefan Tietze. So, und dann antwortet jemand Stefan Tietze, Fragezeichen, und ich antworte Stefan Tietze, Punkt. Punkt. Und die Person antwortet, ach der, ja, in der Kommentarspeite, die Person antwortet, ach der, den fand ich früher auch mal gut. Ah, okay. Und ich antwortet nur, Schnecken-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji. Ah, okay. Totenkopf-Emoji. Okay, Jesus, du hast ein Schnecken-Problem. Aber, das ist lustig, dass du es sagst, weil es gibt dieses Jahr wirklich ein Schnecken-Problem. Es gibt so viele Schnecken. Regen, Regen, Regen und dann kommen die Schnecken. Woher weisst du das? Ich habe beobachtet, es gibt vor meinem Anwesen, gibt es einen Grünstreifen, der gepflegt ist. Grüngürtel. Ein Grüngürtel. Speckgürtel. Speckgürtel. Die Mieten steigen. Und immer wenn es regnet, dann hauen die Schnecken ab aus ihrem Gras. Ich weiß noch nicht genau warum, also warum die dann nicht regeln. Angst vor Flut. Flut. Aber die sind doch selber fast nur Wasser, oder? Eben. Ist eine Schnecke nicht fast wischend? Und dann gehen die alle über den Weg drüber und dann kommt der Igel. Da-dem. Da-dem und der Igel. Und er frisst die alle auf. Wirklich? Ein Igel. Der frisst alle fucking Schnecken auf.
Aber ganz kurz, wofür haben die ihr scheiss Haus?
Nee, die haben doch keine Schnecken.
Ich meine jetzt hier Slug.
Ich meine jetzt hier Nacktschnecken.
Ja, aber der könnte ja auch.
Okay, gut.
Ich meine die obdachlosen Schnecken.
Ja, gut.
Die sozial benachteiligten Schnecken.
Die mag ich so gern.
Ein Igel.
Und die Schnecken können gar nichts tun. Nichts, die haben keinen Plan. Und frisst alle Igel auf. Und dann kommt Florentin. Und frisst alle Hals den Adler auf. Alle. Die können nichts machen. Wer ist das? Wer ist das? Moment, Felix Lobrecht. Das kann nicht sein. Und frisst alle Podcast-Defoos auf. Aber ich könnte mich zumindest verteidigen. Ich habe diverse Tritte, die ich einsetzen kann. Ich habe auf X den hohen Tritt, auf Y den niedrigen Tritt. Und ich drücke einfach nur X die ganze Zeit. Hoher Tritt, hoher Tritt, hoher Tritt, hoher Tritt. Der Gorgonzola kommt. Gorgonzola. Die Schnecken können nichts machen, die können nichts machen. Die haben keinen, also in so einer Schnecke geht das rote Licht an, du, du, du, du, schnell, schnell, schnell, der Igel kommt, das Protokoll. Dann blättert jemand nach, einfach erste Zeile leer, zweite Zeile leer, dritte Zeile gefressen werden, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji, Totenkopf-Emoji. Okay, und wie bist du jetzt da verfahren? Also du, es kommt immer noch Mails. Ich gebe mir Grösse, ich gebe, ich dachte, du redest noch über die Schnecken. Ich bin wieder bei den Mails. Ich gebe mir Grösse Mühe, die Schnecken nicht auch noch zu stampfen. Ich fahre mit meinem Fahrrad, Behände schlängelnd vorbei, weil natürlich Rutschgefahr besteht auch. Und einmal habe ich es nicht geschafft und ich bin über eine Nacktschnecke drüber gefahren. Die Nacktschnecke hing am Reifen, wurde einmal komplett über den Reifen mitgenommen und dann vorne rausgeschossen, wie ein absolut lebensverachtendes Geschoss der Schnecke. Einfach zu sagen, wer hat eigentlich auf dem Planeten Erde nochmal die Macht, die Schnecke oder der Mensch?
Wir gucken mal kurz nach. Die Schnecke liegt am Boden, macht nichts. Der Mensch rast mit einem Stahlfahrrad drüber und rotiert einmal den Schneckenkorpus um 180 Grad und katapultiert dann die Schnecke ins Nichts. Kat will springen woanders hin, wo ein kleines Mädchen vor der Mutter steht mit ihrem Tornister und sagt, Mama, die hänseln mich alle, aber heute wird vielleicht ein guter Tag.
Ich habe aber so Angst, dass sie mich weiter hänseln. Aber ich gehe jetzt da rein und ich bin, wie du es gesagt hast, heute wird mein Tag, weil mir geht es nicht gut. Die hänseln mich. Gestern bin ich auf der Banane ausgerutscht und alle haben mich gehänselt. Das schaffst du schon, Schatz. Heute gibt es keine Bananen. Okay. Und dann geht das kleine Mädchen zu den Freunden. Hallo. Ah, da ist ja Luisa wieder. Ah, hast du eine Banane mitgebracht? Und währenddessen die Schlecke klatscht ihr in den Mund rein. Ja. Was? Ja, das ist es. Das ist das Problem. Das ist passiert. Ich glaube, und das ist jetzt wirklich kein Witz, es ist extrem gefährlich, Schnecken zu essen. Also ich habe ein Bild gesehen, war so eine Schraffur, also wie so ein Tiefdruck, also wie so ein Kupferstich, aber auch als Holz, Holzstich. Und das war so eine Art Meme mit so einem Typen, ja, tolles Leben, dann hat er Schnecke gegessen, unheilbare Krankheit, hops. Hops genommen worden? Hops genommen worden? Fennig, hops genommen worden. Über den Jordan. Über den Jordan genommen und da heisst es Don't Eat Slugs. Und da dachte ich mir, gut, dass das endlich mal jemand sagt und die Leuten, die wirklich snacken, snacken über den Boden. Es ist komisch, dass die nicht lecker aussehen, weil eigentlich hat ja dieses braune, glänzende, längliche, eigentlich einen enormen Reiz. Also wirklich dieses schleimig, bräunlich-längliche hat ja wirklich eigentlich einen enormen Reiz. Wir waren ja, du weißt, Evolution spielt in diesem Podcast immer eine grosse Rolle. Korrekt, das wird sich auch nicht ändern. Alle, die da Angst haben, das wird weiterhin Thema bleiben. Wir haben wahre Thesen aufgestellt, wir haben immer wahr, immer Fakten und, wie ich es nenne, alternative Fakten hier vorgestellt. Ja. So, jetzt haben wir beide immer gesagt, okay, Survival of the fittest, wer ist der Angepassete, die gehen weiter, noch geht nach vorne, wir lieben die Angepasseten. Das ist hier das Tizische Theorem. So, aber jetzt habe ich neulich eine Doku geschaut über Hunde.
Und da war zum ersten Mal, habe ich es gehört, die Rede vom Survival of the Friendliest.
Oh!
Und das fand ich spannend, weil die, und das ist ja viel smarter, haben sich irgendwann angewöhnt, die Wölfe früher, haben sich an den Menschen drangehangen, weil die hatten
immer noch ein bisschen was zu essen über und haben gemerkt, je süßer sie sind, deswegen
können Hunde ja auch mit als einzige Tiere, können ihre Augenmuskeln so bewegen, dass man das Weisse sieht und dann sehen sie so süss aus, weil sie menschliche Augen haben. Der Mensch vermenschlicht das, denkt die Gefühle nach und hat diesen Hunden mehr gegeben. Es gab so einigermassen natürliche Zucht. Und diese Hunde leben ja das bessere Leben als die Menschen, die jagen müssen. Die Hunde essen einfach, was überbleibt. Du, also das ist ja wie zu sagen, wenn ich mich jetzt an so einen Milliardär dran hänge. Du machst grosse Augen, einen Milliardär. Genau, so dran, klebe.
Und hängst einem dran, ja, am Fuss, der ist so mitgeschafft.
Und was der so fallen lässt von seinem Muffin, das fängst du dann auf.
So ein Milliardär, der ist ja nichts auch.
Das ist ein gutes Leben, ja.
Ja gut, für so einen Hund vermutlich ja.
Ja, und dann werfen die die Stöcke noch immer, mega gut.
Da haben die richtig Bock drauf.
Ich glaube ja, dass Hunde auf vieles, was wir denken, dass sie mögen, überhaupt keinen Bock haben,
sondern einfach nur mitspielen.
Vielen Dank. Mega gut, da haben die richtig Bock drauf. Ich glaube ja, dass Hunde auf vieles, was wir denken, dass sie mögen, überhaupt keinen Bock haben, sondern einfach nur mitspielen. Dieses ganze Stockwerfen, ja wirf den Stock, ja wirf den Stock, die haben da keinen Bock drauf. Die wollen, dass du glücklich bist. Genau, die wollen, dass du denkst, dass du sie glücklich machst und das macht sie wiederum glücklich. Ja, es ist dieses, wollt ihr noch einen Shot, wollt ihr noch einen Shot? Und alle so, ja, yes, noch einen Shot, es ist das Beste der Welt, es ist so geil, jetzt will ich noch einen Shot trinken. Eigentlich, du gehst ja eigentlich nur in den Club, um den Barkeeper glücklich zu machen. Ja. Dass du nach Hause gehst und denkst, alter, der Barkeeper hatte heute einen richtig guten Abend. Hast du gerade gedacht, dass der Barkeeper die Frage stellt, ob wir doch schon vorhin vorhin waren noch nie im Club. Achso.
Moment, wer fragt, hä, aber der verkauft doch die Shots. Freunde. Der verkauft doch die Shots. Freunde, Freunde gehen zu dir und sagen, wollt ihr noch einen Shot? Sag mal, ihr wollt doch noch einen Shot. Und dann heisst es, ja, nein, Rita will einen... Ich glaube, niemand will das so gern, ich meinte auch scheisse. Allerfieler verziehen danach das Gesicht, okay? Indiz Nummer eins, dass es vielleicht nicht so geil schmeckt. Ja, ja. Ja. Und dann sagen trotzdem alle ja, weil du dich nicht enttäuschen willst. Und die Hunde sind wahrscheinlich genauso. Ja, ja, okay, das stimmt. Survive of the friendliest. Mich würde natürlich interessieren, warum das nur für Hunde gilt, weil... Es gilt nicht nur für Hunde. Mich würde es natürlich interessieren, welche Tierart sagt, Leute, wir Biber haben es jetzt lange probiert mit den Dämmen, ich würde sagen, wir brauchen was Neues, wir Biber, wir steigen ab. So eine klare rote Liene Tendenz nach unten. Und die Biber so, wisst ihr was, und dann einer eine Idee, ich weiß, eine radikale Idee, aber ich würde sagen, Dämme, Bäume, Nagen, vergesst es. Das ist 2023. Das ist die Democratic-Partei der Biber. Diese progressive, wir gehen weiter. Richtig, die sagt 2024, friendly Biber. Aber auch weil Klimawandel, Wasserpegel steigen, die Biber sehen sich einer Übermacht gegenüber. Ja, ja, ja, keine Chance. Und der Democratic-Biber, nennen wir ihnennen wir ihn. Bernie Bieber. Okay. Bernie Bieber, okay. Und dann natürlich gibt es dann den Populisten. Republican Bieber gegenüber. Donald Trunk. Wir bauen weiter Dämme. Wir bauen die besten Dämme. Auf Deutsch. Hat das im Hinterkopf. Hat das noch niemand gemacht. Hat das bei eurer Kritik jetzt gerade im Hinterkopf, dass es auf Deutsch ist. Wir bauen die besten Dämme. Wir bauen weiter Dämme. Das Wasser. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Wir bauen die höchsten Dämme. Bei mir und meinen Rallys kommen die meisten an Landbiber. Ich hab die meisten Biber. Wo kommt das Schilf her? Das Schilf kommt aus China. China. Bernie Bieber will friendly sein. Er will sich anbiedern. Ich sag Bernie boring. Make Bieber great again, make Bieber great again.
Und wer gewinnt die Wahl am Ende?
Weiss man nicht.
Weiss man auch nicht.
Aber weiss man auch nicht.
Soweit sind wir nicht in der Zukunft, versprochen, dass wir schon wissen, was passiert.
Das weiss man nicht.
So, und Bernie Bieber sagt jetzt, pass auf, wir vergessen es alles, raus mit den grossen Zähnen, wir gehen voll auf Makeover, wir versuchen unsere Augen zu betonen, dass die menschlich aussehen, wir versuchen so auf zwei Hinterbeinen zu laufen, den Schwanz so ein bisschen einzuklappen oder so, dass der nicht so wuchtig, bedrohlich aussieht, wir wenden uns an Menschen. Wir zwingen diejenigen sich vorzufassen, die den buschigsten, süssesten Schwanz haben. Genau, weich. Und diesen Lederlappen. Diesen immer leicht feuchten, modrigen Lederlappen. Nee, den nicht. Nein, nein. Der soll weggingeniert werden. Und dann geht eben die Biber, setzen alles auf eine Karte, Karte, Glubschaugen, Mensch, süss, cute Biber, und dann versuchen die dem Hund Konkurrenz zu machen, sich auch anzupassen. Währenddessen der Mensch umringt von einer ultrasüssen Schlange, einer ultrasüssen Biene, dem Hund und einem ultrasüssen Biber. Und der Mensch sagt so, ah, wen nehme ich so? Und dann ist Evolutionsdruck. Irgendwann muss man doch noch essen. Und alle gehen auf die kleinen Kühe. Ja, dann dreht sich der Mensch so um zu den Erdbeeren und die Erdbeeren mit so Riesenaugen.
Hallo, fuck, hallo, wirf die Frisbee.
Ja, gerne.
Dann kommt er zu den Gurken und die Gurken sagen, wir sind auch da.
Ja, und was sagen die Kirschen? Wir haben dir die Zeitung mitgebracht.
Hallo, hallo, wir sind zwei.
Wir sind immer zu zwei, weil wir uns lieben.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist halt die Gefahr, dass halt alle irgendwann sich nur noch an den Mensch dranhängen, weil man einfach merkt, da macht niemand mehr sein eigenes Ding. Ich liebe ja den Biber dafür, dass er seine eigenen Dämme baut, dass er gerade nicht nach unseren Regeln spielt. Wir wollen ja das Wasser, gluck, gluck, gluck, her mit dem Wasser, aber der Biber sagt, das machen wir aber gar nicht so. Wasser, stopp! Warum bauen Biber Dämme? Weil die nicht wollen, dass ihre Heimatdörfer überschwemmt werden. Sag mal, du kommst ja irgendwann selber drauf. Man muss nur langsam genug sprechen und man findet eigentlich jede Lösung. Die bauen Dämme, damit Beaver Town nicht überschwemmt wird. Ich glaube, weil die einfach da gerne schwimmen, oder? Und ich glaube, weil die da gerne schwimmen, okay. Ich glaube, die haben da gute Karten. Sagt das nicht so sassy. Die haben da, glaube ich, einfach gute Karten. Wo gute Karten? Im Wasser. In Wassernähe, das sind ja Amphibien. Gut, aber da brauchen wir ja keinen Damm. Und ich hatte das nicht auch was mit den Tieren zu tun, dass sich dann die Tiere an... Verfangen. Weil dann gibt es auch ganz viele... Nee, bei stehenden Gewässern kommen ja andere Tiere zum Vorschein als bei fliessenden Gewässern. So in stehenden Gewässern, da kommen dann die Wasservögel, die Wasserläufer, die Wasserratten und alles, die kommen dann rum und die fressen die Wieber, glaube ich, oder anders, weiß ich nicht.
Die Ratten des Feuers, die Ratten der Lüfte, warum bauen, ich bin nicht so stolz. Das Ärgerliche ist, dass ich die Antwort mal kannte und jetzt leider vergessen habe.
Das haben wir auch schon mal hier.
Und es ist wahrscheinlich so was, es hat wahrscheinlich was mit Waldbrand zu tun, dass die dann nicht verbrennen oder so und solche, dass die dann Wasservorräte haben oder so. Wächst eine Biberpopulation an, werden auch Gewässerabschnitte mit geringerer Wassertiefe besiedelt, an denen Nahrungsressourcen oft schnell erschöpfen. Dann werden Dämme gebaut, um neue Ressourcen zu erschliessen und gewässernah fressen zu können. Aber es gibt ja auch Leute, die halten sich Biber als Haustiere und die bieben dann auch. Die bauen dann Dämme im Haus. Die nehmen sich irgendwelche Stofftiere und fangen an, Dämme zu bauen bei Türen oder so und hauen halt einfach die Dämme raus, weil in denen drin ist, dass sie Dämme bauen. Das finde ich faszinierend. Zum Schutz vor Feinden liegt der Eingang immer unter Wasser. Sowas, ja, ich bin so dumm. Wenn der Wasserstand nicht ausreicht oder zu stark schwankt, baut der Biber Dämme. Also nur wenn der Wasserstand nicht ausreicht oder zu stark schwankt, weil der muss immer unter Wasser sein, der Eingang. Wer ist der Feind des Bibers? Dachse. Der Lachs. Dachse. Lachs, Dachs. Nee, nee, Lachse, dann würden sie ja über Wasser den Eingang bauen. Ach so, ja, okay. Dachse, Wölfe, Luchse. Luchse, ja. All diese B-Tiere. Das ist kein S-Tier, ist kein A-Tier, es sind B-Tier. Ja, ja. Luchs, äh, Fretchen.
Und der Mensch.
Mensch würdest du aber bei B einsortieren?
Tierlist der Lebewesen, Mensch auf B?
Ja.
Okay, interessant.
Du meinst, du Mond geflogen, oder?
Das ist ja schon beeindruckend.
Affen auch.
Äh, bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Ja, nee, aber Affen hätten's gekonnt.
Wie hätten's gekonnt, das kannst du ja nicht sagen.
Wie, wenn was. Ja, wenn sie sich so entwickelt hätten.
Ja gut, aber haben sie ja nicht. Also ich meine, klar.
Bienen können das auch.
Bienen können nicht zum Mond fliegen.
Warum nicht? Nur weil sie das nicht wollen, heisst das nicht, dass sie es nicht können.
Die Flügelchen heben, die haben die Luft wird zu dünn irgendwann und dann können wir nicht mehr weiterfliegen.
Okay, warum können wir dann durch das Weltall schlippen?
Weil wir Raketen bauen.
Ja, und warum können Bienen keine Raketen bauen? Weil die winzige Stummelfinger haben und so dumm sind. Das ist eine scheiss Tierlist, Stefan. Das ist eine... Du hast wirklich komplett nur Bullshit gemacht. Da kommt kein Bullshit. Warum ist Milbe auf A? Warum ist Milbe über Mensch? Milbe ist übermächtig.
Milbe ist überhaupt nicht mächtig, winzig klein.
Ich krieg die nicht weg.
Ja so what, die stören auch nicht.
Doch klar stören die.
Ich mach die Liste wütend.
Die richtig wütend, die ganze Milbe auf ... die ganze Milbe über Mensch, du ... also ...
Unser Mitbewohner hat gesagt, wir sollen diese Tierlists machen, damit wir uns ein bisschen besser verstehen.
Aber du machst immer dumme Tierlists.
Du streitest mich immer.
Vielen Dank. Er hat gesagt, wir sollen diese Tierlists machen, damit wir uns ein bisschen besser verstehen. Aber du machst immer dumme Tierlists! Du streitest mich immer! Warum nicht immer? Immer ist alles schlecht! Okay. Wir haben eine Antwort. Okay. Aber wir brauchen noch eine Frage. Aber du hast recht. Survival, wir müssen das untersuchen. Survival of the friendliest. Ja, wir müssen gucken, werden Tiere näher, also süsser. Werden Tiere süsser? Zum Problem, ja genau. Also weil irgendwann ist ja auch, das Problem ist ja ein Marktwert, ne? Also wenn jetzt alle Tiere gleichermaßen süsser werden, dann wird ja das Verhältnis wieder sich geändert, weil dann finden wir die Tiere nicht mehr süss. Der Mensch hat ja schon die Macht und neigt dazu, Tiere, die süss sind, künstlich am Leben zu halten. Ja. Pandas gäbe es ja nicht mehr, wenn die nicht sauknuffig. Ja gut, sorgen nicht die Menschen auch dafür, dass es viele Tiere nicht mehr gibt, also dass sie die Pandan die Bambus wegessen. Ja, die hässlichen, das ist ja das Spannende, die unfreundlichen hässlichen. Und deswegen wollte ich es ergänzen um Survival of the Cutest. Guten Morgen, Herr Dachs, ja, der kann aussterben, die unfreundlichen Tiere. Ja, der deutsche Dachs, der ist wahrscheinlich ausgestorben, weil er fucking unfreundlich war, immer mit seinen Socken in den Sandalen so rumgelaufen ist. Entschuldigung, Herr Dachs, wir würden übers Wochenende in Rügen fahren. Wir erwarten aber ein Paket. Kann ich dem Postboten sagen, dass... Nein, auf keinen Fall! Weil Sie haben den Bau hier direkt bei uns vor der Tür. Ja, das ist doch kein Problem. Planen sie halt besser. Sie haben es ja noch falsch bestellt. Ich nehme ihre Pakete nicht an, weil ich bin zur Woche bei mir in meinem Eingang. Da gab es eine Verzögerung. Ich bin zur Woche bei meinem Eingang. Es ist ja nur einmal, da gab es eine Verzögerung beim Liefern. Join das hin! Schleich die! Den letzten Satz noch auf Bayerisch gemittet. Das ist wirklich eine gute Entscheidung. Rausgehen kann man immer gerne mit dem Dialog. Bayerisch. Ja, immer, warum nicht? Ja, weil, pass auf, Survival of the Friendliest ergibt für mich total Sinn. Survival of the Cutest ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Ding. Ich finde, Friendly ist ein komisches Wort. Warum nicht cute? Friendly ist, also welches Tier ist denn freundlich? Also freundlich ist, wenn die jemand die Tür aufmacht. Oder wenn du noch einen Weg fragst und kriegst eine nette Antwort. Das ist für mich freundlich. Aber Tiere sind, also, Tiere sind, die haben angefangen zu helfen.
Also diese Rudel haben sie als nett... Entschuldigung, sie haben ihren Geldbeutel verloren.
Entsteht ein roter Pudel hinter dir, oder?
Nein. Erstens, vielleicht ja.
Zweitens, die Wölfe, von denen ich damals
spreche, waren halt nicht mehr aggressiv,
sondern haben sich sozusagen
ein bisschen angefreundet mit den Menschen.
Was würdest du sagen, ab welchem Punkt soll man jemanden darauf hinweisen, dass er was verloren hat? Beispiel, eine Packung Taschentücher fällt jemandem aus der Hose. Ist komisch, dann einen Monat später hinzugehen und zu sagen, dass die Tasche die haben verloren. Man nimmt es mit und verfolgt die Person und beobachtet sie über Tage hinweg, um dann eines Tages beim Klassensprechertag der Tochter vor der Schule zu warten und zu sagen, ah, fehlt Ihnen etwas? Haben Sie Schnupfen? Ich war freilich in einer fremden Stadt. Warum machst du deine Geschichten immer so mysteriös? Weil da … Du warst in München. Nee, es war nämlich Florenz, deine Stadt. Oh, Bella Florentica. Es war deine Stadt, es war Fiorentina. Fiorentano. Da komme ich ja her ursprünglich. Dein Name zumindest. Da wurde ich gezeugt. Dein Name, ja? Ja, da kommt der Name. In so einem Turist Hotel. Das bist du. Mit billigem Reiswein und Crepe. Mit so einem Nutella-Bananen-Crep. Ja, am Frühstück. Da wurde sich so gestritten am Abend noch irgendwie. Geh mir doch mal raus. Nee, hab keine Lust mehr. In so einem Turi, du bist ein Turi-Fallen-Typ. Ja, trotzdem schön wunderbar. Okay. Kein Fan von Florenz. Naja, egal, das gönnest du dir nicht hin. Das tut mir leid, da fühle ich mich jetzt persönlich verantwortlich. Ja, nee, und dann bin ich da, wie man das halt so passiert, man ist im Handy und irgendwie in diesen alten Städten, Google Maps, so ein bisschen lost. Und es ist neu, dass du das machst mit dem M. Das macht alle in meinem Umfeld, das ist mir schon zweimal aufgefallen, fangen Leute an, immer M zu machen. Fällt es dir vielleicht jetzt einfach mehr auf? Ich mag das nicht. Leute machen M. Das ist so eine Bestätigung. Hör dir noch mal alle 427 Folgen an und guck, ob ich schon immer M gemacht. Ach so, es geht dir gar nicht um hm. Wo ist das fordernde, freundliche hm hin? Ja, das hast du immer gemacht. Ah, okay, jetzt, ich erinnere es mich. Es fühlt sich gut an auf der Kehle. Ich hasse das nicht, aber so sage ich das auch nicht. Ich sage nicht hm. Das ist mir schon unerwartet zum dritten Mal in dem Umfeld aufgefallen. Das ist nicht so. Also wenn du was sagst, sag ich nicht.
Google Maps ist oft lost.
So sagt das keiner.
Das ist viel offener.
Sowas würde ich mir fast wünschen.
Hör es dir gerne nochmal an.
Jedenfalls bin ich dann, waren da auch gerade so Schulkind, aber Schulschluss irgendwie. Und dann war da so ein Kind und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, hat es mich angeguckt. Ich glaube, weil ich auch so lost wirkte oder so, aber ich habe mich dann so ein bisschen ausgelacht gefühlt. Okay, wie alt war das? Also, ich war sechs bis acht, klein. Und deswegen ist es mir aufgefallen. Und dann bin ich dem erst hinterher, weil Google Maps das gesagt hat, und dann hat Google Maps so einen Schlagart einen U-Turn gemacht und ich bin weggegangen. Und das Kind, ich glaube, das war, ich habe gesagt, ja gut, die Florenzer Jugend, die Fiorentina-Jugend lacht mich jetzt aus. Ja bist du das Gesplött von ganz Florenz. Und dann hat das wieder ein New Turn gemacht, weil der Kompass im Arsch war. Und dann bin ich wieder hinter dem hergelaufen, hinter dem Kind. Und dann war der Weg genau. Und weil es war irgendwie so etabliert plötzlich, Blickkontakt, es war eine Verbindung etabliert.t, und dann glaube ich bestimmt für zehn Minuten hin dem Kind her. Und ich fand das so lustig, weil an dem Punkt habe ich noch gesagt, mit dem ich unterwegs war, wenn das Kind sich jetzt umdreht und rennt, einfach so auf Spaß so zehn Meter mitrennen. Okay, okay, Definition von Spaß.
Doch, einfach mal Spaß.
Und dann in dem Moment, wo wir es gesagt haben, klingelt das Kind bei sich zu Hause. Und wir kommen an und das Kind wirklich so auf das Ding gedrückt, weil wir das viel zu lange verfolgt haben. Ja, und das kennt man ja manchmal so nachts, wenn man hinter einer Frau hinterherläuft oder sowas, und man zu viel gleich einen Weg hat und man merkt, die Frau fühlt sich irgendwie verfolgt oder unwohl, dann wechsle ich auch gar nicht die Strassenseite, damit das aufhört. Was aber dann auch so ein predatory Verhalten, ehrlich gesagt, ist. Es wirkt wie dieser Velociraptor, der dann plötzlich weg ist. Und dann ist er genau vor dir. Soll man nicht telefonieren, glaube ich? Habe ich auch mal gehört. Also tun, als würde man telefonieren. Ja, Schatz, ich bring jetzt, du, die hatten leider nicht mehr das Mousse au Chocolat, ich hab dir jetzt dieses Rotwein. Also irgendwie so als banale Gespräche, oder? Hi Schatz, ja, sie hat ein weisses Kleid an und ist so um die 19 bis 20. Ja, ungefähr deine Grösse. Ich bring dir das in der Hause. Deine Grösse ungefähr, ja. Hey, das geht. Einfach genau all in, einfach Hannibal Lecter oder diese Buffalo Bill wie bei Schweigen Gelämmer so. Ah, ich kann mir genau vorstellen, dass ihr Hautstück von ihrer Schulter noch perfekt passen würde auf unser Mannekerl. Ja, ja, unangenehm, unangenehm. Florenz, um das kurz abzuschliessen, kein Fan. Es ist touristisch überlaufen, natürlich gibt es wahnsinnig viel Kunst, die Stadt ist an sich wunderschön, aber ich habe das Venedig-Problem. Ich habe das VP. Ah, okay. Dadurch, dass... Du hast nur in Italien, habt irgendwie... Ja, gerade viel Italien. Kein gutes Gefühl, habe ich irgendwie... Doch, doch, ich liebe Italien. Also ich habe das Gefühl, da liegt was in der Luft. Nee, irgendwie bei euch Krieselz. Ich liebe Italien. Krieselz da gerade, glaube ich, im Urlaub, Stefan. Aber ja, miram oder... Ich glaube, da Krieselz gerade irgendwie so ein bisschen. Nee, hast du nicht das Gefühl, Venedig, irgendwie Florenz? Doch, die Touristen. Ihr habt das Gefühl, die Enttäuschungen häufen sich irgendwie. Doch, ja. Man ist einer von vielen Leuten, die da hinreisen. Nichts, nichts Besonderes.
Ich müsste eigentlich eine Stadt für mich entdecken, wo man da ein bisschen unter Einheimischen ist.
Aber ich kann einfach Städte nicht mehr ertragen, die zu 80 Prozent aus diesen Souvenirläden mit I Love Stadtname-Shirts bestehen. Ja, also Pisa kannst du skippen. Pisa muss, Pisa muss, das kannst du dir sparen. Pisa kannst du skippen. Jesus. Wir haben das gebaut. Und dann haben wir es schief gemacht? Wir haben das alles für euch gemacht. Das ist ein cooles Motiv. Wir hatten diese Idee, dass man sich da vorstellen kann und so tun kann, als würde man den Turm schützen? Ja, ich bin ja in Kindheit oft auch in Italien in Urlaub gefahren. Ganz klassischer Urlaubsort Caorle kennt man natürlich auch. Caorle? Caorle. Das hilft, er sagt nicht, dass du das Ding jetzt. Caorle. Colle. Und die haben auch so eine Altstadt und auch mit einem schiefen Turm.
Und der Turm ist halt auch schief.
Und ich dachte mir immer schon so... Carmen, meine Geburtsstadt, hat auch einen schiefen Turm.
Gibt es überhaupt noch gerade Türme in diesem Land?
Zeig mir einen!
Auf diesem Kontinent!
Ist es denn so schwer, einen Turm zu bauen, mit einem Lot in der Hand, gerade, anscheinend? Ja, das Lot kann ich ja erst von oben runterhalten, wenn der Turm schon steht. Ja, aber dann kannst du ja noch eine Kurve bauen. Konnten wir nicht. Könntet ihr doch. Da haben wir kurvige Türme. Ja, besser als schief. Warum? Dann ist es halt wie so eine Klammer zu, so ein Turm. Dann geht es halt einmal einen Bogen und dann oben ist es zumindest nicht schief. Sieht es doch positiv. Man kann ein Foto machen, wie man ihn hält. Dafür ist er nicht schief genug. Also baue ich ihn dann richtig schief. Der Kamener Turm ist nicht schief genug. Der schiefe Turm von Kamen ist ein Kirchturm und der ist leicht schief und zwar gegen die Windrichtung gebaut. Bewusst schief. Ach so, na, aber vielleicht denn bewusst, dass der Wind, dass er nicht in Windrichtung umknicken kann. Wie gesagt, bewusst schief. Bewusst schief, okay. Ja, bei Coola dachte ich immer so, ja, ist das jetzt auch so ein Touristending so oder nicht, dass das irgendeine Attraktion ist, aber am Ende habe ich mir auch einfach so viel Krepp mit Banane und Hotella reingestopft, dass ich nicht mehr über diese Gedanken nachdenken musste. Ich habe die einfach ertrunken in wirklich süsser, süsser, flüssiger Nutella, die einfach meine Kehle heruntergestürzt ist. Kaorle. Oh, so herrlich. Turm. Schön, also richtig schön. Oh, der ist auch schief. Einfach richtig. Aber der ist wirklich nicht schief genug, ne, der ist auch an sich nicht schön.
Kommt natürlich auf den Winkel an, ne, also wie gesagt, jeder schiefe Turm ist aus einer Richtung gerade. Das haben wir auf tausende T-Shirts gedruckt, die jetzt alle auf dem Grund des Meeres liegen und dort wahrscheinlich tolles Zuhause für Hummer oder Muränen oder was auch immer bietet. Ist schon cool. Ganz ehrlich, der Schiebeturm von Pisa, der ist wie so zu sehr gelernt, dass man gar nicht akzeptiert, also man checkt gar nicht mehr, wie cool das eigentlich ist, dass da so ein richtig schöner Turm so schief steht. Weißt du, wie so, wenn man Bandnamen zu oft sagt, dann sind man… Die Toten Hosen, man versteht gar nicht, wie genial der Name eigentlich ist. Genial weiss ich jetzt nicht, aber … Ich finde die Toten Hosen ist genial. Du denkst nicht mehr an tote Hosen, sondern du denkst an die Band oder an die Musik oder so Silbermond. Du denkst ja nicht an einen silbernen Mond oder was für ein Quatsch das ist, sondern du denkst an die Quatschmusik. Und beim Schiefenturm von Pisa, Shots werden rausgehauen. Das hast du nicht nötig, Stefan. Ich habe eine Idee für meinen Bandnamen, The The. The The. Gibt's das schon? The The. Ich habe eine Idee. Drop The The. Nur The. Nee, die Band. Ach so, okay. Ja, okay, wir haben auch versucht, einen Song zu schreiben, und wir sowas, alte Daten, die will doch keiner sehen, alte Daten, will doch keiner hören, alte Daten, lösch sie so schnell du kannst. ist nicht schlecht und dann dachten wir, uns hat irgendwie so richtig der Hook. Ist das so Informatik-Lieder? Drucker Treiber! Ja, genau. Ich update dich heute Nacht, Drucker Treiber. Okay. Ich druck dich nochmal aus. Gleiche Melodie, das ist ein bisschen das Problem. Aber anderes IT-Problem, okay. USB-Kabel. Ist das der gleiche Song? USB-C. Das ist ein neuer Song. Neuer Song, weil es die gleiche Melodie ist. USB-Kabel. Das ist die gleiche Melodie. UBS-Kabel. Falsches, ist es der gleiche Song? PDF-Datei. Jesus Christ. Ja, deswegen. Gut, dass du einen Deckel darauf gemacht hast auf die Band.
Wenn bei euch irgendwie vor einer Woche oder so
mal alles IT-mässig
runtergefahren ist oder
euer Internet kurz so ein Hiccup hatte,
liegt es wahrscheinlich an mir. Oh, was hast du gemacht?
Du hast versucht, das gesamte Internet runterzuladen.
Nein. Du hast einmal Apfel A
gemacht und dann hat der Automatisch
das gesamte Internet ausgewählt.
Wann mich aufpassen.
Du hast Rechtslich downloadet.
Nur in geschlossenen Räumen, Command A, download.
Nein, schlimmer.
Warum da war denn das so lange alles runter?
Und das ist wie, genau, und dann sieht man so die Karte von der Welt, Licht überall und alles fährt so runter.
Nur in Köln ist so ein Licht, ganz hell an.
Ne, schlimmer, ich habe auch Schlimmeres gemacht. Ich habe eine PDF verändert. No, das geht doch nicht. Wie geht das? Sag mir das doch, dann kann ich beim Unfall sagen, hiermit nicht. Und das würde ich sagen, ist mein drittes nunmehr schon Wunder. Du hast eine PDF verändert und du hast dafür gesorgt, dass eine Mail, die du verschickt hast, wieder zurückgenommen wurde.
Ich habe an eine No-Reply-Mail geantwortet. Ich habe eine PDF verändert und ich habe durch Null geteilt. Und das an einem Wochenende. Und das an einem Wochenende. Was war so wichtig, dass du es geändert hast? Musstest du dein Logo, Stefan hat das Logo, musstest du dein Logo auf deine Steuererklärung, auf dein PDF irgendwie mit in Rechnung nehmen? Nee, es war was Rechtliches und das war falsch. Und dann wollte ich es ändern. Du hast schuldig geändert in nicht schuldig, aber der Richter hat da einen Fehler gemacht. Ich habe so eine komische Angst, dass wenn ich diese Datei, diese PDF-Datei in so einem Photoshop-Ding öffne, weiss ich nicht mehr genau, ob das geht, wahrscheinlich schon, und dann mache ich wie so einen weissen Kasten drüber, habe ich die Angst, wie bei so einer Wand, die man streichen muss, dass man den Weisston nicht erwischt. Ja. Und dann sieht man dann nachher, wenn man es ins Licht hält, so ein Flecken. Ja. Und dann sieht man, er hat die geändert, die PDF verändert, aber so peinlich. Hat der da Zahnpasta in die Löcher der Wand gemacht? Das ist doch ein ganz anderer Weisston. Wie Moltofil. Ja, das ist doch ein ganz anderer Weisston. Ja, diese Angst hatte ich. Oder dass PDFs, weiß ich nicht, ob die so Pigmente haben, wie so ein Blatt Papier. Naja, das kommt auf ein, du musst das natürlich erst so bearbeiten. Also da gibt es so Staub und gewisse Essiglösungen. Ja, ja, dann geht das schon. Ich dachte jetzt wieso, wenn du, Tippex siehst du ja auch auf einem Papier, da siehst du aber, es wurde was geändert, das ist peinlich ein bisschen. Ich wollte professioneller rüberkommen mit diesem Link. Vor allem, wenn du Liebesbrief schreibst. Genau. Und vor allem den Namen irgendwie achtmal mit Tippex übermalt hast, das ist irgendwie komisch. Genau, ich musste den Namen nämlich ändern und wollte dabei seriös rüberkommen, das war wichtig, und dann habe ich eine Website gefunden, die dann eine PDF ändern kann. Im Dark Web? Ja, ich musste erst in den Tor-Browser, erst in den Tor-Browser runterladen. Und dann im Tor-Browser musste die URL kennen, denn nur, es finden nur die Leute die Seite, die schon wissen, wo sie liegt. Okay. Tortuga. Ja, dann habe ich die PDF da geändert. Wahnsinn. Ich habe tatsächlich mal einen Liebesbrief geschrieben und dann so viele Fehler gemacht, dass ich gesagt habe, ich fange nochmal neu an, weil ich wollte nicht den Brief verändern. Und dann habe ich nochmal neu angefangen und den abgeschickt und die erste Version habe ich aber bis heute aufgehoben. Das heißt, ich habe nicht den originalen Liebesbrief mehr, sondern ich habe nur noch die alte Version, von der man ableiten kann. Ich habe mich in der ersten Version ein bisschen verrannt, weil ich habe zu dem Liebesbrief noch einen Film verschenkt. Gedreht? Nee, verschenkt. Und ich glaube, ich bin zu sehr auf den Film eingegangen. Was für ein Film? Fight Club. Ja, genau. Aber dann warst du schon älter, dann warst du 16, 17, 18. Ja, ja. Ja, mit welchem Alter schreibt man denn Liebesbriefe? Sechs. Mit sechs? Weiss ich nicht. Ich war schon immer ein Spätzünder, aber deswegen habe ich immer Angst. Wenn ich sterbe und das wird dann alles aufgearbeitet, denken die Leute, das seien die Liebesbriefe, die ich schreibe, aber es stimmt nicht, das ist die erste Version. Never mention the Fight Club und du sagst, okay, ich schicke den Film, ich verstehe den Film und rede da sehr viel drüber in den Liebesbrief. Ja. Hast du ihn verschickt? Was war die Reaktion? Stille. Glaubst du manchmal, wenn du diesen fehlerhaften Brief siehst, dass der vielleicht erfolgreicher gewesen wäre? Kann sein, ja. Ich weiss gar nicht, ob das sogar sympathisch ist, wenn Liebesbrief ankommt mit Dingen, die durchgestrichen sind. Eben. Ob das nicht eine Art von, ah, der gibt sich Mühe oder da ist Arbeit reingeflossen mit viel Tipp-Ex. Oder es ist saud. Ist saudumm, dass immer konsequent, also ich habe kein Problem, wenn Leute statt SSS schreiben, aber dann auch noch statt SSS bei das, also komplett umdrehen, also die verstehen ja anscheinend den Unterschied, aber haben einfach verwechselt, verdreht. Es ist ja kein Problem, das zu ändern, aber irgendwie so das, so und da ist halt die Frage, er löscht, er löscht, er löscht die Liebe. Erlascht. Erlascht sie im Anbetracht von Grammatikfehlern. Ja, Grammatikfehler sind natürlich ein bisschen unsexy. Ja, wirklich? Aber, ähm, handgeschriebene Fehler sind ja was anderes, zum Beispiel als, ähm, WhatsApp-Fehlerehler. WhatsApp-M. WhatsApp-Fehler haben ja keine passieren. Handgeschriebene Fehler sind ja ein Fabrikat von äusserster Absicht. Äusserster Absicht. Handgeschriebene Fehler sind einfach ... Ach so, ja, weil du es nicht auf irgendeine Technik schieben kannst, meinst du? Ja, WhatsApp schreibt man ja so blalalalalala mit seinen Daumenfingern, langen Fingernägeln, schreibt man da so brrrr, rein, rein, einfach rein. Und dann auch so meinetwegen, liebe, schau, Fight Club, hier ist der Link, aber in einem Brief, wenn du es denkst, du hast dich ja hingesetzt, du hast wahrscheinlich einen Brief vorgeschrieben, du hast die Fehler in die Tinte getaucht, da und dann schreibst du, das kann ja keinen Fehler beherbergen. Naja. Und du bist halt strunzendum. Ich ziehe gerade ja um aus Köln und misste da aus und habe ja meinen alten Liebesbrief wiedergefunden. Ach so, ich dachte, weil der Brief. Ich versuche nicht zu fliehen, ich sehe dem ins Auge, aber naja, ansonsten, falls die Person sich noch melden möchte, ich warte. Er wohnt nicht mehr in Köln. Also die neue Adresse hast du dann bekommen. Mehrmals. Stimmt. Stimmt. Du musst an diesen Brief... Guter Punkt. Vielleicht sollte ich einen... Ja, ja, Umleitungsscheiss musst du machen. Er wird für ein paar Monate wieder eine Post umgeleitet. Bitte nur Liebesbriefe umleiten. Genau. Keine Rechnungen. Rechnungen in den Müll, Liebesbriefe direkt in mein Baumhaus. So machen wir's. Bei mir an der Klingel hängt noch von der Frau, die ja vorher drin gewohnt hat, hängt an meinem Briefkasten, bitte keine Werbung, ausser für Schuhe, ein Sticker. Bitte keine Werbung, ausser für Schuhe und dann so ein Smiley, so ein girly Smiley. Und es ist ein vorgefertigter Sticker? Ja, der hängt dran, ich kriege den nicht ab. Das ist so, mir ist so peinlich. Aber eins muss man dir lassen, Stefan, du trägst wunderschöne Schuhe. Ich weiß, ich kriege so tolle Werbung für Schuhe, ich kriege so viel Werbung und ich liebe es. Grossartig. Ja, ich hoffe, ihr hattet auch viel Spaß mit der Werbung in dieser Folge, denn es war reichlich.
Haut rein und hört gerne nächste Woche wieder mit rein.
Bis dahin wünschen wir euch viel Spaß, entspannt euch, erst keine Schnecken, macht's gut.
Wir leben beide gleichzeitig, weil wir lieben es, uns zu verabschieden.
Ciao!